If you’re familiar with the SCP Foundation,
then you already know the exact reason why
there are multiple SCP-001s.
You may even think you know which of them
is the real SCP-001.
But for those of you who are new here, or
who just need a little reminder, the designation
of “SCP-001” doesn’t refer to a single
creature, object or entity,
but rather a collection
of various anomalies that are apparently kept
in containment by the SCP Foundation.
At present, it is unclear why there are multiple
files collected under the shared designation
of SCP-001.
Some believe it is because these anomalies
are some of the earliest ever contained by
the Foundation.
This would mean that they share the designation
of “SCP-001” as they were likely encountered
before the SCP Foundation introduced their
current numbering system.
However, there also exists a theory that this
is nothing more than intentional misdirection.
Perhaps, the multiple SCP-001 files are an
attempt by the Foundation to conceal information
about the true SCP-001.
After all, it wouldn’t be the first time
this hyper secretive organization deceived
us.
Anomalies sharing the name SCP-001 include
the infamous Scarlet King, the massive Gate
Guardian, and the world ending event known
as When Day Breaks.
But today, we will be using SCP-001 to refer
not to an entity or an event, but to a location.
A location codenamed…
God’s Blind Spot.
Located in an unassuming corner of the world
is a site that the SCP Foundation constructed
and designated as Facility T. According to
their archive, it’s a largely unremarkable
place, situated at a spot on the Sinai Peninsula
- which is a part of Egypt that forms a bridge
between the continents of Africa and Asia.
In the eighteenth century, archaeologists
excavating the area uncovered the remains
of a stone structure, believed to be an inn
that dates back to the second millennium BC.
However, since the construction of Facility
T, any trace of this structure
has since disappeared.
So, what makes this unremarkable site so important
to the SCP Foundation?
Why establish a facility if there was nothing
anomalous about its nature?
What distinguishes this SCP-001 site in the
eyes of the Foundation is the area’s profound
lack of any ambient Akiva radiation.
But what’s Akiva radiation?
Well, according to the Foundation’s researchers,
it’s a form of cosmic background radiation,
one that’s not overtly harmful to human
beings.
If you grew up in a strict,
church-going household,
then it’s highly likely you would have been
exposed to a lot of this non-electromagnetic
radiation and never even realized it.
You see, the thing with Akiva radiation is
that it is directly correlated with the amount
of religious faith a person has.
Regardless of which religion someone follows,
Akiva radiation will form around them.
It tends to be harmless to humans, however
certain anomalous entities and SCPs considered
to be demonic in nature can be repelled and
even fought off with high levels of Akiva
radiation.
The presence of other powerful anomalies,
those considered more benign and even holy,
can also create an increase in this radiation.
SCP-001 has earned the nickname “God’s
Blind Spot” for a number of reasons, one
being that it is the only place on Earth with
a natural absence of this Akiva radiation.
The Foundation has conducted experiments that
involved bringing sources known to emit Akiva
radiation into the area of SCP-001, but when
they measured, no change in radiation levels
was detected, meaning that the space around
Facility T does not actively block Akiva radiation
from entering it, but also cannot absorb or
retain this religious radiation.
It might be more accurate to say that the
location destroys any trace of residual Akiva,
without damaging the source.
A lack of faith-fueled radiation is far from
the only anomalous property of SCP-001 though.
During a number of tests involving D-class
personnel, the Foundation witnessed that,
while in this area, it also becomes impossible
for the death of any human being to occur,
a discovery that obviously needed to be researched
further.
The first test involved a healthy human male
who was left in a containment cell on the
SCP-001 site and observed.
He had no supplies, no food, no water, yet
over one hundred and twenty days, this man
stayed alive, never succumbing to starvation
or dehydration.
Next, a female member of D-class was exposed
to a lethal dose of cyanide gas within Facility
T and suffered none of the expected effects.
Foundation researchers then repeated this
cyanide gas test using thirty common brown
rats, all of which were killed, proving that
it was only humans that couldn’t be killed
while within SCP-001.
God’s Blind Spot seems to also be able to
slow or halt the effects of terminal illnesses,
as proven when a D-class with stage four cancer
was brought into SCP-001.
Despite her prognosis stating she would be
dead imminently, the woman survived in the
area for almost eight hundred days.
Her cancer symptoms never advanced, and she
only died after finally leaving the area of
SCP-001.
There are limitations to this anomalous effect
though.
One test involved cremating a healthy male
D-class while he was still alive.
The man’s body caught fire just as you would
expect it to, and he was burned to death.
According to the findings of that test, and
similar variations, Foundation researchers
have learned that the life preserving qualities
of SCP-001 don’t prevent death by extreme
external damage.
One of the final tests to take place within
SCP-001 involved a pair of twenty four-year
old identical D-class twins.
One of the twins, designated Twin A, was held
at Facility T, while the other, Twin B, was
imprisoned in a cell at a different Foundation
site.
After observing them for over 26 years, Twin
B aged naturally to the age of fifty.
His twin, however, did not appear to age at
all over the course of two and a half decades.
It was only when moved to another facility
that Twin A began to show signs of aging.
The aging process for Twin A was rapid too,
and eventually he caught up with his brother.
Being a benign, non-threatening anomaly, the
Foundation have been more than happy to use
God’s Blind Spot to their own advantage.
Facility T was specifically established on
this site to house the headquarters of the
O5 Council, the overseers of the entire SCP
Foundation.
It’s hardly surprising that the overseer
council would want to set up shop here.
After all, it’s the one spot on Planet Earth
where no human being can ever die of natural
causes, and will not age for the duration
of their stay.
Of course, this locked the O5 Council to one
location, but what if they could replicate
the effects of SCP-001 elsewhere?
Of course this is what the SCP Foundation
attempted.
Following their research into God’s Blind
Spot, the Foundation’s own Doctor Marvin
Scranton attempted to artificially recreate
the area’s anomalous effects somewhere else.
His hope was, by generating a vacuum of Akiva
radiation, that a second instance of SCP-001
would occur at a location of his choosing.
Or, as his assistant Bertrand put it, they
planned to build a box and then push God out
of it.
As it turned out, God had other plans.
Doctor Scranton quickly realized the hubris
of his scheme.
The Akiva radiation in the selected area rapidly
dropped to zero, just as planned, but then
something unexpected happened.
Scranton detected an increase in Humes.
These are essentially parts of the fabric
of reality, and are what’s often disrupted
by reality bending SCPs.
Something had come into our world thanks to
the O5 Council’s attempt to recreate SCP-001,
something impossible for the Foundation to
measure or observe.
In other words, Scranton had no idea what
he unleashed, or where it went.
Following this incident, the O5 Council realized
a worrying increase in the anomalous incidents
they were encountering.
Whether or not this came as a direct result
of their meddling with the fabric of the universe
was unclear, but it forced the Council to
reconsider the focus and direction of the
entire SCP Foundation.
Up until this point, they had been an organization
focused purely on research, but now they had
to embrace a new approach to how they handled
anomalies.
From then on, the Foundation’s objective
became to actively seek out and contain anomalous
entities, creatures, objects, and locations
like SCP-001.
Rather than just observing these phenomena
for study, they would Secure, Contain, and
Protect.
The final portion of SCP-001’s file is a
memorandum detailing an arrangement between
the O5 Council and an unknown “counterparty.”
In the document, someone named Sheldon Katz
sets out revised terms for the Foundation’s
continued use of Facility T. Sheldon states
that he has reached an understanding with
the counterparty, and that the contents of
the document are to serve as a formal agreement,
a contract of sorts between the SCP Foundation
and someone else.
According to this contract, the incident with
Scranton put a strain on the relationship
between the Foundation and
whoever the counterparty
is, and that the O5 Council are seeking to
make amends in order to continue their new
goal of collecting and containing anomalies.
So, who was this counterparty that the Overseer
Council was so desperate to appease and have
on their side?
Who could possibly be a higher power than
the most powerful secret organization on Earth?
Well, an actual higher power, of course.
That’s right, the O5 Council were making
a deal with God, over how they were allowed
to use his Blind Spot.
Or at least, a very powerful being that considers
itself to be God.
The rules laid out in their agreement stated
that no person was permitted to stay at the
site of SCP-001 for more than a hundred and
twenty years, including members of the O5
Council, along with any
other members of Foundation
staff, management, researchers, security personnel
and test subjects.
Additionally, the SCP Foundation’s Ethics
Committee was required to annually report
any and all of the O5 Council’s decisions
to God.
For his own part, God was restricted from
smiting or exacting his terrible wrath upon
any member of Foundation personnel.
That’s right, a perk of working for the
SCP Foundation is getting around the clock
divine protection, at least from God himself.
That’s still a lot better than an employee
dental plan.
This came with a condition however, that anyone
committing a transgression or mortal sin was
given a ninety day written notice, and an
opportunity to repent their wrongdoing.
In return, God demanded that members of the
Foundation only worshipped him and no other
divine entities.
“I, the LORD, am a jealous God, visiting
the iniquity of the fathers upon the children
unto the third and fourth generation of them
that hate me” was written in the contract.
Finally, the agreement between the O5 Council
and God was that they would work together.
The Foundation and the counterparty would
be equal partners when it came to the containment
of SCPs and anomalies.
Of all the strange and unexplained phenomena
that the SCP Foundation encounters on a regular
basis, it hardly comes as much of a surprise
that they’ve got a direct line to the big
guy upstairs.
Or at least one who purports to be.
Still, the fact that the O5 Council have a
business arrangement with an ultra powerful
deity like being, and express written permission
to use his Blind Spot where no person can
die or age, is hardly a comforting thought.
At least the SCP Foundation only ever uses
its power for good… right?
Now go check out “SCP-001 - Which is the
Real 001?” and “SCP-001 - When Day Breaks”
for more SCP-001 action!